is there to sleep
bursting into the clear and a reverse
what a move by damien lillard
seven seconds for the quarter
smell that step back
oh opportunity for lillard foy shaking
his head as if to say i should have
known better
blazers trying to take advantage millard
again from near mid card he hits it
timeout clippers yeah what time is it
damon i'm late to crab oh he had a layup
and then mccullough hey downtown wow
right here
passed up the three twice
cj always spun dirt completely around
and hit the three
that's worse than a poster a spin around
he's one of the better assists man in
the nba but he's not one of the better
three-point shooters oh lillard how did
he hit that up off the glass he was met
by a couple of bigs inside luke walton
said that ankle probably if he's a three
chasing people around maybe a little
easier with him on the floor oh what a
play by lillard
right down the lane with a hammer more
experienced guy might have given him a
technical on that one
millard goes back door
looks for help finds plumley that's
assist number six for lillard you know
it just depends on
how much offensively the other team boy
had it mccollum find his way through
that crowd and then banked it in
dimension four of 14 charlotte five at
12. miller picks up the foul on batuman
hits the shot
nick with two say don't do me like that
you're my friend to match up with they
have three guys that can get their own
shot that's why they don't get
lowry blocked by lillard hard and dame
talks to his bench trying to get the
team going
ready to make his move switched on
capella beverly gets back to him lillard
carving through flips it up and in what
a move from damien lillard with a tenth
of a second to go
la to the rim and henderson oops the
alley from lillard on a beautiful
delivery and von lay says i got it
out to lillard remember now blazers look
[Applause]
hits the shot and he's foul larkin was
trying to take the foul
[Applause]
played by ariza
goes to the beautiful spin and scores
one move by damien lillard
baseline had a couple of white shirts
hanging on him
and still spun it off the glass
lillard
from midcourt this will count
[Applause]
his hands and cj's razors down two nine
seconds mccallum takes it off the
dribble for the tie yes 5.4 left timeout
washington lillard against wall
dame behind the back to the lane throws
it up and
how'd that go in
boy you can't play better defense than
john wall just did that's just a better
shot by lillard who has 39.
shot clock at four lillard well away
from the rim with two mavs on and fades
for three oh he hit it over novitskiy
and dirk shrugs and looks at the ceiling
and rolls his eyes jay has timeouts if
he wants him
midcourt dribbles gets to the lane gets
bump scores and he's fouled
7.6 left and a chance at a three-point
play
[Applause]
lillard at the rim spins it up
that's the shot of the game to clear out
as he went down
cj baseline
score the bucket and he's fouled he
never dribbled again
off the glass
and leroy richardson says count it
three-point attempt
cj can't get one away lillard
gets it away
scores and he's fouled
four-point opportunity yes
man of the year instant offense
missed everything
[Applause]
shot oh
lillard able to get it to go
what a circus shot from damian lillard
right
crab delivered over the top of the
screen makes a great catch look at that
move knifing into the air and leaning
him with the right hand off balance and
got clobbered to boot and kevin i mean
certain nights if you terry stops you
don't really lose anything when you go
to the bench
oh my goodness
the right hand jam from lillard and
attitude
here we go
[Applause]
brother lays it in with two and one ten
seconds remaining in a timeout call by
denver marie will defend lillard with
five seconds with three lillard makes
his move on marie for the wedding
[Applause]
remaining that's one of the foul won't
get it probably in the back tap alertly
gets it away from steph recovered by
damien splits apparent defenders
counting and countdown bucket off the
window lamar come on why not kills off
two defenders to allow teammate to get a
rebound
maybe in the other way look at butler
just take that lane away and forcing him
into a really tough acrobatic reverse
beautiful move
out of comes to mcconnell
freezes hollis jefferson on the davis
screen pumps a three hand
and comes down right through the
it's cuz they have some openings there
blazers with three turnovers here
earlier there's a backdoor lob up top
flying
to the top of the roof at msg with
lillard and bringing it down strong with
two hands there's the rebound they need
and here comes cj make that lillard with
under a minute remaining into the lane
lillards trying to scoop a shot up and
then and he did may have gotten hackman
and goes happy to see the blazers back
in town for one of the rare appearances
in december lillard
[Applause]
chris dunn being extra physical on cj cj
might be able
to draw a foul oh my goodness dunn
leaves cj he's wide open and nails a
three from way downtown and a career
high for cj mccollum timeouts trailing
by three plumley to bring it in bounce
from the end line
they cast it outside cj and catch a shot
is about it
[Applause]
[Music]
crosses over between defenders and laid
it up and in what a magnificent move
that was as the blazers now pulled it
within 14 and a timeout called by the
warriors he said i'm living the dream
he's got six threes here's mccullum two
seconds left mccullum gets rid of
matthews lets it fly at the horn heads
up
to end the first half celtic games in
the 80s
mccullum into the lane beautiful play
going to the right hand around powell
and a timeout by dallas
lovely looking cj open works between
matthews and barnes into the lane
three tenths of a second remaining for
the dallas mavericks they got a heaven
harris will down the floor comes and he
overshoots the rim blazers win the
middle of the paint
blazers led by as many as 13 in the
world oh you don't see that very often
but when you do
you got to replay that one at some point
cj with the hammer down in those later
rounds
looking down that shot clock now down to
four here comes lillard oh what a pass
what a throw
heartless hammers at home team 71
into the lane damien off balance flick
with a left hand on the window
spun in another beauty
here in this ball game
and the blazers down one here's cj into
the lane banged it up and he stumbles as
he fell over the fallen defender to take
the lead with one and a half to go in
the third given mino a lot of credit and
i played him real quick oh dame dollar
oh what a finish
now that is a prime time finish been
able to
dictate the pace of this game behind the
back into the low point of a man down we
have a man down oh no as damian scores
on the behind the back
flutter ball he's got 25 tonight by 12
602 to go third
i quarter right now we're seeing
oh
what are we seeing we're seeing damien
lillard
rise up
from nearly half court
cj peels out goes up the floor looking
for a hit ahead but rushes right with
him dame to the inline to the baseline
goes up and under ah twisting left hand
rivers off the window oh that is a
beauty and the blazers lead at 199
straight away look
shot contested
crab recovers cj on the flow behind the
back into the lane feathers it up and in
what a magnificent move
two blazer guards have been unstoppable
lillard from way downtown
[Applause]
[Music]
hurricane here in a late season deal
with denver and they went 14-6 once they
got good field
mccullum
beautiful play like having thighs on
damian lillard you got brandon ingram
with those long arms guarding lillard up
top
lillard picked up by ingram
lillard
this is for the win
[Applause]
they've got the lead and the lakers
[Music]
splits a pair of defenders drives into
the lane and rolls the dice right off
the window
on his belly there in front of the bench
cj comes off the screen of turner turns
the corner rams into brooks recovers and
scores
at the end of the second quarter cj
mccollum will have the last word seven
and seven ten seconds left in the corner
lasers down three dame the other way
to even it
back
right down broadway
the door is still open lamar for the
blazers
damien turns the corner and he got it he
got hammered too and is able to flick it
up there and spin it in
they threw it away 13 turnovers in the
way are warriors
gets by durant and throws him in the
right hand
hello oakland
lakers trailing here by three
cj the other way look at that crosstalk
come on
[Music]
to cj 13 seconds as he brings it across
mid-court on the nurkic screen cj into
the lane running right-hander up hangs
on the iron and rolls in blazers take
the lead 111 to 110
san antonio ball they use timeout with
five and nine ten seconds remaining in
the game
[Music]
houston the lead at twelve turning the
corner damian takes all right to the cup
and he throws it down with the right
hand whoa the hammer thrown bound by
lillard that's stevenson to defend as
well he's a good defender
deputy inbounds to cj fires over corey
joseph three is up and in
how about that
cj says never give in or does he is he
just playing the uniform at this point
to play a legend here
goodness pick him up somebody pick him
up clean up on out three
[Laughter]
five of them
in double figures 31 for lilly here's
connors
on the magic carpet
curtis and soaring in the two-hand
slammer
turner sneaks to the inline
unloads today
drives it scoops it lays it in he drew
contact in the air
crosses up horn into the lane warren
slaps it free
two seconds left the shot is up
way up top off the rafters for the tip
jam hillard handling looking over the
shoulder drawing
cj out to him
they do not switch peyton stays on
little or drives into the lane to the
glass
off the contact he scoops and scores
sons will bring it inbound
daniels from backcourt it falls just
short the blazers win this game
davey and lillard you have done it again
[Applause]
damian
off the screen got chow he scores hits
the three chopped down from behind and
still able to angle it up and end he
gets rid of it they're in denial making
sure somebody else has got to take
mccullum over the baseline
hung in the air and then banked it in
screens set by lillard into the paint
seven to shoot for damian lillard
fighters from way downtown nothing but
net for lillard
thompson has to fade away with cj right
up in his visage off it comes damn cuts
between defenders comes in with a hammer
blow and a right hand jam to put the
blazers on top by one chip away but like
you said quality gotta get a quality
shot
damn outside a three and fouled
damian lillard
between defenders springs for three and
he heads to the line how about that
dribble handoff to cj
goes right up the gut to the right
bringing it down the pike with a
two-hand jam that's how you start
overtime
dante exum who's done a nice job off the
bench play-making and playing defenses
in
deep three by cj mccollum
late in the clock it's cj mccollum
throwing it out to aminu for three
needed that one in front on the inbounds
volley then tip grab by nurkic guns it
ahead to lillard lillard into the paint
turns swings it to aminu makes a
tremendous catch back today
[Applause]
damien lillard from the outer limits
reels in a three still operating blazers
their best to put them away cj into the
lane contact
floats it up and in
send the man to the line
you can see the blazers have two
timeouts left denver two damien goes to
work has to get it going takes him right
to the rim and he flushes over milsap
lillard shot out of a cannon right to
the rim
[Applause]
oh
hello
they've held the warriors to eight
points here in the fourth quarter which
would by far be a season low
lillard from dave hit it
it's over
he's got the ball right now stride the
three-point arc with 12 to shoot damian
will take it back
goes right at white drives into the lane
draws the bump counted if it goes it
does little backhand scoop show up show
them the pythons
westbrook from behind the arc
is now one of four
he is three for 15.
shooting in this game lillard with a
30-foot bomb
[Applause]
wow damien lillard he's got three of
those 30 footers in this series already
a long ball by dame coming up with felt
it on him we'll cross over step back
three-pointer is up
a chance to send the thunder home
lillard long range three
[Applause]
jokic and the rebound throws it ahead
murray murray down the court jet black
oh mccullum with a block he said
basically i don't want to be considered
somebody you can attack that i'm the
weak spot on rt
beautiful pass by mccullum
leaving it for a cutting white sox
[Music]
cj dame
high catch swatted away by ubra cj
recovers gets off the three beats the
clock nothing but net
[Music]
[Applause]
cj sets his feet drives benbry to the
end and eases it over the cuff before
parker could get there yeah he he snuck
him on that one
the hornets have put 43 points on the
board in the period
a three from graham back iron rebound
trip up the dame at the buzzer
[Applause]
buzzer
with a half minute to go coming up the
american express halftime report what
three lillard
[Applause]
difference of two and a half seconds
game clock and shot clock
willard
working on perks dancing free a three
game
he's got seven to fire on top to lillard
fumbles it away shot clock at three
has the defense in front long shot by
dane right down the hatch
off into the corner ariza back out on
top to dame
nice handle
behind the back flips the right side for
the two-hand jam
[Applause]
lillard pulls off just past half point
but but i when i look out at what you
would want your nba player
to look at oh my goodness wow
jamie and lillard
to protect the paint on pick and roll
so they're not up to contest the three
the same as zubach does it this
feed mccullum slick pass for nurkic
and a foul call of anybody in the league
they find certain players to go at and
they get you in foul trouble
oh
and dame we're gonna just break that
down for you here real quick
richardson really up in the grill of
damian lillard here eight seconds
dame able to force the foul the bucket
and damien lillard
he was six of nine
oh my look at this shot by whatever
goodness
that was from the nba logo oh my
goodness what a shock you gotta be
kidding me people
damn catches it in the back court 13
seconds left to go for the blazers they
trail by one
dame into the paint finds cj cj for
three oh painted cj mccollum
blazers take the two-point lead
cj with his ninth three of the knights
they've worked so well together they
don't care who gets the shine
cj's been going
blazers just trying to match them shot
for shot that string together some stops
cj down the paint draws the foul and the
bucket
cole schatz wants them to just play
blazers have a chance here cj
ball in hand rises up for two it's good
[Applause]
of the screen
roko saves it to little
[Applause]
dame
deep dish serves it up to the bulls and
one all the entire time and that makes
that possible to get the jump ball dame
with 41 gary tran jr to jump against a
two-time slam dunk champion
lasers get the tip five seconds left
covington trying to get it to dame he
puts on the floor step back three from
dave oh
paint painted damien lillard
game winner in chicago
back to back threes to break the heart
of the bulls
wow
it's that time
damn time blazers with five three-point
shooters on the floor they trail by one
lillard with ball defending
he goes to his left and once bumped by
paul and one damian lillard with a
chance to give the blazers a two-point
lead
try to get something going here
two seconds left lillard from the logo
it's good
logo lillard
[Applause]
with 20 seconds to go in the half
oh my
you see what you started reggie what i
started see what you started that should
be a new rule when you're up this much
you got to end it on a three if you need
three all right what's willow picking
about here
he's thinking about games
the three
and it's all over
that's what he's thinking about game
time
game time baby tipped in though by
gobert with one point one left
nurkic fires it down court caught by
mccullum got away and scores at the
buzzer
what a pass down the court by nurkic
allow for morris to grab it cleanly my
goodness
on the line
9.8
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
lillard eight assists 21 points van
vleet
inside the bar rejected by cj
spikes it away powell lead past a little
into the lane outside the dame a dribble
adjustment for three got it mouse of the
proverbial house he's double team now by
adams kick it out of there
dave's got two to shoot
you gotta flip
why not why are we why are we surprised
don't be surprised